donc il ya une grenouille qui font
beaucoup de bruit et une autre espèce de
grenouille qui s'appelle la grenouille
taureau qui est une grenouille énorme
qui peut devenir grosse comme ça et qui
mange tout on va faire des gros titres
en terre et je vais vous montrer comment
on va faire et c'est parti pour une
demi-heure de sculpture pour ses quatre
enfants
une occasion pour eux d'apprendre en
s'amusant pour se protéger les
grenouilles parce qu'elles sont
importantes c'est pas souvent qu'on peut
faire une grenouille déjà et puis j'aime
bien modelés
j'aime bien la sculpture l'atelier fait
partie des quarante exposants sur le
festival de la biodiversité
au programme par exemple des producteurs
locaux ou encore une association qui
sensibilise au recyclage des déchets ici
grandes et petites entreprises se sont
réunies on a deux objectifs 1 c'est de
faire échanger tous les acteurs donc
institutions entreprises associations
bon et de motiver le grand public parce
que chacun a quelque chose à faire
vis-à-vis des déchets vis-à-vis de ces
comportements de la consommation
d'énergie j'avais en tête des vieux
ordis à la maison qui était bon usage et
anciens et pour n'utilise plus et que
peut-être on pouvait en faire quelque
chose et j'ai peut-être trouvé du coup
quelqu'un qui va pouvoir peut-être qu'on
arrive et recycler nos ordis donc voilà
au moins je sais pas mais pour aurélia
la première édition a réuni 1100
personnes
les organisateurs comptent en programmer
une deuxième l'année prochaine